when Patrick Beverly said Chris Paul is
a
chair nine times all defensive team
seven first team did you think about
saying something about it did you think
about did you not see it it made it to
me first and foremost paraly to say
anything I get it I done had many of
times in my career where somebody done
said this or said that the work speak
for itself I still compete on defense
every night as best I'm probably not the
defender I was some some years ago when
he did that I was like whoa ah I was
like damn it's so hot if you actually
really listen to Pat talk he say some
good but I was like ah because when
I saw that I'm like don't become the hot
take guy the world that we in now people
going to say something you got to give
it that 24 hours I'm not a guy who when
something happened I run to my phone you
know what I'm saying and post this or
post that or whatnot you just stand on
the work